I have to let you go in about a moment
so you know it is time for the
inevitable turn towards Marvel and
Thunderbolts I hope I can ask you some
safe questions
cut off the internet connection yeah
really your high-speed internet suddenly
is gone yeah exactly how that happened
yeah getting the opportunity to direct a
Marvel movie is a really big deal but I
am curious more about accepting it from
a personal perspective as a director
when you were offered the chance to
direct Thunderbolts what did you think
you would gain from that opportunity as
uh as a director evolving his craft I
think you know
what what jumped out was I mean first of
all the cast is just incredible and I
think like any movie with that cast like
how could you not be excited about
getting to work with that group of
people
um and then also you know John Watts's
my roommate from college and we're good
friends and so knowing this what a great
experience he had making those films
something that's certainly and I I even
did second unit on like the LA portion
of one of the Spider-Man movies so like
having a little bit more kind of
connection or insight into that world
um but beyond that it was just like a
really different approach and a new kind
of story to tell amidst that which I
know I've made so many things but it is
you know it's not a sequel um and it's
not you know yes these characters have
appeared before
but it is a news story being told in a
story I think with a very different
perspective than maybe people are
expecting and I think that that
felt exciting and felt like a real
challenge worth picking on with that in
mind and also some of the work I love
from you so much like like beef
obviously because we're talking about
that now but I'm also obsessed with
brand new cherry flavor that is a
phenomenal series when I think about
shows like that though I don't
necessarily watch them and say like that
guy's the right one to direct the next
Marvel movie which I actually do think
is a good thing and winds up exciting me
even more so I guess what can you tease
about the the tone the style and the
atmosphere of thunderbolts that will
indeed make it stand out and maybe tap
into some of those things we've seen you
uh do on screen before yeah I think in
the end it's I mean obviously I can say
so little but I think it's just about
it's about characters and is there
something specific to those characters
that bring them together and something
that they're going through that isn't
you know the most traditional superhero
you know story to be told and I think if
you can hit that and if you can make it
specific I think if you look at
something like beef what makes it what
it is is that it's
so specific on so many levels you know
Sunny brought so much of himself to it
Alex even everyone and in being that
specific becomes something Universal and
I think that's sort of similar to the
way that we're looking at Thunderbolts
is that there is a real
clear taken perspective on these
characters and there's a specificity to
it that in the end obviously we want to
make the big Universal movie that
everyone can connect to but that you can
only do that by making something that
feels personal and I think that's what's
exciting about the project to us I like
the sound of all that I'll dare to
squeeze in one more question because you
have you have the the unique qualities
that you are going to bring to the
franchise but of course it also has to
still feel like an MCU movie so of all
the past Marvel films maybe films that
you were watching or re-watching to prep
to actually direct Thunderbolts which
one did you find influencing or have
because it's still ongoing influencing
your approach to that film the most oh
man that's a tough
there's so many good ones I just this
isn't this is going to totally avoid
your question but just because it's he's
my good friend on this I'll just pick uh
I'll just pick a Spider-Man homecoming
just for just for John just so I don't
get in trouble with my friends how about
that I respect it's not gonna be like
our movie but but it is it is very good
and I hope our movie is very good here's
my my one selfish pitch for you because
you're good friends with John and John's
working on another favorite franchise of
mine of all time you should talk to him
about looping you into the ongoing Final
Destination franchise especially because
Jordan's kill feels like it's in that
world
I had not but thank you for I had not I
had not made that connection yet but I
am very excited about about what he's
making in that world that's good in
college that was I remember
in the dorm room with him and Duncan and
forward but I'll sit around watching
Final Destination all the time and
talking about the kills so I think fans
will be in very good hands with John's
work on that I've got very high hopes in
him and that team